I do have this sort of secret shame that
I've only just begun to share with
audiences but the night after this last
election I accidentally a trump
voter yeah hear me out I was drunk
it was last call he walked in the I
generals and I said let's go and halfway
back to my apartment he finally turns to
me and he's like how about this election
and I was like I can't believe I didn't
ask about this it's crazy what's gonna
happen to our country I'm terrified and
then just the longest pause imaginable
and he was like yeah but he has some
good ideas and it was like I feel like
I've spent the last ten years of my life
telling conservatives online to suck my
dick and then one finally did you know
and I hated it thank you so much good
[Applause]
Oh No I'm gonna set up heat in the
bathroom ah holy I know right oh my
god I don't even know what to do with
that
I think I'd need more than like a condom
as protection like I want to take this
dick to court and get a restraining
order against this peanut that's gonna
be a no for me dawg
ya know ticket to Hollywood for this
penis come back next season
maybe my car sir I'm not used to a New
York City crackhead like I'm from the
south so a more genteel like a crack
gentleman is what I'm what I'm used to
somebody who really cares about the
people he's stealing from my crackhead
in Atlanta once came up to me and he was
like hey miss lady um I really hate to
tell you this but I caught somebody else
going through your car okay what is else
yeah it's dead right oh my god you came
yeah I came I said I was gonna come okay
someone's cute in person
Thanks didn't you say you were like with
a group of people that's a figure of
speech is that oh you're a comedian
funny boy I bet you are really funny I
can tell I like to think I am so what is
this this is like a stand-up is this
like improv you have like a team it's
like happening now is it happening later
the show actually happens in that bar
over there this is more like the back
bar what comedians come to be alone and
Center themselves before the set oh it
could be alone big yeah okay well good
thing I came because now you have
company let's just get a drink right
excuse me hi I like a drink that's why
I'm sitting here I'd like to not wait
longer please I'd like a sprite I think
he's doing his best
oh yeah we don't know him and we don't
know that well I do I mean I see him I
have to see him a lot thanks okay so a
little about me I have never lost a
Pepsi challenge oh cool
[Music]
so should we go make out so it's coming
back from my father's memorial service
and a co-worker came up to me and she
said oh wow so both of your parents are
gone and I said yeah unfortunately that
is the case and then she said Wow don't
you wish you had had kids so they could
have known their grandkids on a bagel
and you handed me an existential crisis
thank you thank you good morning thank
you that is not how my live-in boyfriend
of six years does it wait what okay well
thank you so much for that experience
but in the meantime I think the show is
actually happening right now so I should
like to clarify I am their best friend
but they're not my best friend
so I set the record straight really
quick